Big day today, DALL-E 3, the third version of the
legendary text to image AI is coming! No, we can’t
try this yet, there is no product or paper yet,
only the initial announcement. Now, it seems that
it does three things better than all the other
techniques out there. So, what does it do well?
Well, first, it listens! Now, I hear you
asking, Doctor, what do you mean by that? Well,
with other techniques, important parts
of our prompts often get lost. However,
not here. When we enter a detailed prompt, it
really tries to take all of it into consideration.
If I write the prompt, I want to get that
moustache to be noteworthy, and this one,
I would say, is. And some of these prompts can get
bloody long, and I just kept looking and looking,
but I think I might see everything that was
requested here. Even for things that are
really really difficult to paint, sometimes,
even imagine. Try to imagine a whirlwind of
porcelain fragments, harmonious fluid forms in
a dreamlike atmosphere and so on. Excellent.
Two, I am wondering, can this really
compete? I mean, Midjourney and Stable
Diffusion have become so incredibly
good, I can imagine that even DALL-E
3 might have a hard time competing. Now,
we have a little indication here. Oh yes,
the legendary prompt from DALL-E 2. “An expressive
oil painting of a basketball player dunking,
depicted as an explosion of a nebula.” And now,
look, this is what it looks like with version 3.
More detail. More definition. More life. I find
it a great deal better. Great job, little AI!
And three, now hold on to your papers Fellow
Scholars, for better integration with ChatGPT.
You see, we don’t even need to write the prompts
directly, we can even ask it to make up a new
character. Let’s call him Larry the hedgehog. And
we get Larry. Larry is amazing, so let’s get some
more images, and now you immediately see that
getting several images created about the same
character is not a trivial matter at all. We’ve
looked at a bunch of papers that tried to pull
that off, and now it is here. But, every hedgehog
needs a house, so it can imagine that too,
that is a beautiful house, and, look at that!
Text! Fantastic. I really want that because
we have been promised proper text support in
text to image, and at least for me, it never
quite worked out without significant cherry
picking. I hope it is going to be better here.
And then, finally, we can ask for
stickers of the amazing Larry,
and even a bedtime story with him. I have a
7 year old daughter and just thinking about
the amount of fun we are going to have with this
gives me goosebumps. Love it. Thank you so much!
Now, one more thing. Note
that there is no paper. Here,
I can only comment on what I see in
the announcement, and the cases that
we see here are usually not the average,
but the best case scenarios. However,
we will be able to try this and find out
soon, no doubt. What a time to be alive!
I was happy to see that it will
not create an image in the style
of a living artist. And when I watch
their video, what do I see? Proper,
and I mean proper scholarly representation,
that is what I see. Well done Fellow Scholars!